Hank: Good morning, John.
I'm in a car! I'm headed to work!
I'm stopped at a stoplight right now; I'm being
safe.
And I wanted to take you with me to work.
I wanted to show you some of the people who work on the things and the place where they do it.
Here we are. It's work.
Hank: We're gonna start with Matthew.
What are you doing right now?
Matthew: Finacial Diet
Hank: Hey there's those girls
Matthew: There they are.
Hank: 'Sup!
Matthew: They can't answer you.
Hank: How are you doing?
Nick: Good, how are you?
Am I talking to the camera?
Hank: I'm at the same spot as the cameraman.
Nick: Yeah, I know, but if I look...
Eyelines's weird, man. Eyeline!
Hank: Oh, Nicole's here?
Matthew: Yeah.
Hank: I'll just pretend that she was here
the whole time. Hey, Nicole!
Nicole: Hi, I've here the whole time.
Hank: Who are you editing?
Nicole: Myself.
Hank: Yeah, I know what that's like.
Hank: Ceri's here.
Ceri: Hello.
Hank: What are you writing about right now?
Ceri: Uh, I'm actually editing Crash Course
Film.
Hank: This is Alyssa's...
This is Alyssa's sad empty desk, because she
lives in New York sometimes.
Hank: Caitlin's here.
Caitlin: Hi! How's it going?
Hank: Good. How are you?
Caitlin: I am reading about ways to start
a new job.
(Hank laughs) Not because I'm looking for
a new job, but because I'm working a script for How to Adult.
Hank: Thanks for making that clear.
Caitlin: Yeah.
Hank: I'm coming in.
Hank: You're our newest person.
Marcus: I am.
Hank: How are you doing?
Marcus: I'm learning how to edit you right
now.
Well, um, more specifically, I'm learning
how to animate on top of you.
Hank: You wouldn't think there's anything
happening in the darkness over here...
...but there is.
Michael: Oooh, the darkness.
Hank: Look at you. This is the darkest I have ever seen it in here.
Behind this door is the scariest part.
Oooooooh.
Hank: Hey, it's Henry!
Henry: Hey, are you doing a tour?
Hank: I am.
So you are... you don't work for me, but you
work in my office.
Henry: This is my office. I rent it from—I rent it from you.
Hank: Right, sorry.
Henry: You crossed into my office.
This is the light that they turn purple when
we're filming.
Hank: This is Marie Ann, who is my assistant. Assists me with all the things. Hi.
Marie Ann: Hello.
Hank: What are you working on?
Marie Ann: Your emails.
Hank: Thanks. How are they?
Marie Ann: There's lot of them.
Oh, look! There's a Julie!
Hank: Hey, it's Julie!
Julie: Hello!
Hank: What's your official title?
Julie: Director of Operations.
Money maker.
Hank: The vast majority of the pictures on
this phone...
Julie: Ooooh!
His cheeks are coming in, nice!
Julia: Hi!
Hank: This is Julia. How are you doing?
Julia: I'm good. How are you?
Hank: Good. Just maps of Amsterdam and Melbourne?
Julia: Yeah, I gotta think about them.
Hank: We noticed yesterday that you haven't
updated your calendar collection.
Amy: Funny you say that...
(Hank gasps) Calendar.
Calendar.
Cows doing Yoga.
Rivers. Ocean.
Uh, available on DFTBA, unless it's sold out...
Hank: Not anymore. We're sold out now.
Amy: Montana Wildlife, and some more Montana.
Hank: That's... That's even more than you had last year!
Amy: I know.
What a cool room you guys have.
Hank: Hey, what are you working on?
Valerie: I'm working on signage for Nerdcon:
Nerdfighteria.
Hank: Oh, do you have program there behind it?
Valerie: Oh, yeah.
Hank: Ooh, oh, ooh, aaah, oh dang!
Hank: Okay, I'm gonna take pictures of all
of you, and put you on my video.
You're gonna have lower thirds.
Valerie: That's a lot of work for yourself.
Hank: Oh hey, why are you on the floor?
Rodney: Hi Hank.
Natalie: Hello.
Hank: I stopped for whatever this is.
Now, I'm going to the warehouse.
I get the feeling that our break table isn't
being used very much right now.
Oh, you've—you're already in the video.
Victoria: Hi.
It's pretty out.
And now I go home.
It's weird, right?
I want to be clear that, like, Vlogbrothers,
still just me.
But all the other things—Vidcon, Scishow,
Crash Course, DFTBA.com, all that stuff—so
many people are necessary to make it happen.
I like doing the business thing, and I like
doing it not in the normal ways.
So I'm gonna keep doing that, and I am excited
for what the future has to hold.
There are lot of people who work on the things
that we do, and I am always amazed by them.
And really lucky to have them in my life.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.